so the l-sit is a movement that you
typically associate with advanced
calisthenics you see people going from
these beautiful v-sits into press
handstands i'm not quite there yet but
that's kind of my point i think that the
elsa is something that everyone should
be doing whether you're interested in
getting a ripped set of abs or they just
want to improve your general performance
and your mobility this is a great
movement that everyone can use we're
going to talk about that right now
and today i'm also joined by grant
stevens who's come to help me get some
more dynamic shots and just hang out and
hopefully we'll be able to do this a bit
more in future grant makes awesome
videos about martial arts training
fitness and lifestyle so if you want to
check those out there'll be a link in
the description down below anyways on
with the show
so the first reason that everyone should
be doing l-sits is that they are a
fantastic ab exercise and a fantastic
static contraction isometric movement
for the abs if you're doing a lot of
plank because you want to build a great
six-pack then you should really be doing
the l-sit instead this is a much tougher
movement and you'll really feel it the
next day it really works the abs hard so
once you're at the point where the plank
becomes easy you can progress onto the
l-sit and you'll see much faster
progress
of course if you can't do an l-sit yet
there are lots of easier progressions
we'll get to in a moment so like i say
this is a movement i think is for
everybody obviously the l-sit is
difficult because you're holding up the
weight of your legs and this requires
not only the hip flexors but also your
core strength because your legs are
quite long your feet are going to be at
the end of that lever arm and that's
going to make movement more difficult
the best way to explain this is to first
talk a little bit about different types
of isometric exercise so an isometric
contraction is contraction in the muscle
where you're not moving through a range
of motion
so if you've got your dumbbells and held
them for as long as you possibly could
that would be an isometric contraction
and specifically that would be a
yielding isometric contraction which
means that you're holding them for as
long as you can until you start to give
out and your arms start to go down
however you're not using your max
strength at any point because you always
could move them higher
if you're using your max strength say
you were pushing or pulling against them
that couldn't move say you had a chain
attached to the ground and you're trying
to curl it that would be an example of
an overcoming isometric and obviously
this allows you to exert a lot more
strength and therefore it can build more
strength more quickly what's great about
the l-sit in the visa is that it has
properties of both it's a yielding
isometric and that you're holding a
position for as long as you can until
you start to lower the legs but you can
also try and lift the legs as high as
possible attempting that v-sit and
thereby you're making it more of a
overcoming isometric because you're
essentially fighting against the
resistance provided by your own body and
this is where this becomes a fantastic
movement for performance because you're
building something called compressive
strength and that's literally your
ability to compress your own body to
bring your upper torso down towards your
legs the reason this is difficult is not
only because we lack the flexibility but
also because we lack the strength and
that combined limits our mobility so
mobility is the ability to get into a
position without external help so
without someone pushing you so if you
can bend over as far as you can and
touch the ground slap the ground with
your hands that's fantastic mobility and
that's going to help you to kick higher
it's going to reduce pain on your lumbar
spine it's going to translate to
generally better performance all around
it'll improve your squat technique so
this is a fantastic way to not only be
training the abs as in building core
strength and stability rigidity but at
the same time to be developing that
compressive strength that will result in
better performance greater mobility and
just generally better movement on top of
all that there are benefits of isometric
training in general this is a great way
to train strength endurance because
you're holding a position and at the
same time it's great if you're dealing
with an injury or rehabbing because
you're not going through a range of
motion you've reduced the likelihood of
hurting yourself further and just in
case you weren't convinced the l-sit is
also fantastic for developing straight
arm strength this is your ability to
exert strength through locked out
straight arms this again translates to a
range of advanced calisthenics movements
famously the planche it can translate to
a better bench press because you're
developing the seratus muscles and the
scapular protraction it can translate to
reduced likelihood of injury during
movements like the deadlift once again
this is a underrated aspect of strength
and something that everyone can benefit
from training the lcs is a real gentle
introduction of an easy way to train
that and you're getting all these other
benefits so yes everyone i think should
be incorporating l-sits into their
training so that's enough talking about
why you should do the l-sit now it's
time that we actually look at how to do
the l-sit um so basically i'm going to
start by showing you on the floor
because that seems like the most proper
way to do it you want to get into a
normal sitting position with your legs
sticking out and now what you want to do
is put your hands flat on the ground and
twist your elbow pits outwards to keep
them completely straight and locked
that's actually not 100 essential but if
you want to get those straight arm gains
and if you want to work on that at the
same time as your core strength then
it's a really good idea to start
practicing that so you're not trying to
get your elbows facing out you don't
need your hands facing backwards it's
just drilling them into the ground
twisting them outwards to straighten out
the elbows uh your hips under your
shoulders and raise the legs like so to
form an l alpha lima or
lion i've been hanging out with my
daughter too long if you find that
difficult if your arms seem to be too
short for your body they're probably not
it is possible but in most cases
what you can do is you can add a little
bit of scapular protraction curve the
shoulders slightly alternatively raise
yourself up onto the fingers like so to
give yourself that little bit more space
and as we were talking about before if
you want to work on that compressive
strength then you need to be trying to
bring the legs actively up not just
holding them in place but trying to
raise them as much as you can and what
you're essentially doing is working
against the resistance provided by your
hip extensors by your hamstrings and by
your glutes
and that way you're going to be making a
more active
exercise and that way you're going to
build more strength more quickly and be
able to hold that position better and
for longer something else to consider
when you're performing the l-sit is to
try and keep the knees locked out trying
to engage the quads this is what's going
to provide the resistance if they bend
slightly at the knee not only does it
look less aesthetic not only will be
harder to transfer to different
movements but at the same time you're
not going to be getting the same amount
of resistance and you're going to build
up to what you're actually trying to
achieve here
another thing to think about and i've
been forgetting to do this a lot of the
time here is to point the toes if
possible not only will this make it more
aesthetic but it'll also make it a
little bit easier because you're going
to not also be fighting a stretch on the
calves obviously if you struggle to
perform a l-sit then the easiest
variation is to put your hands up on
something slightly higher up therefore
meaning you'd have to clear quite as
much ground to raise your legs and you
have to be in a full l i'm going to be
using some parallettes here you can use
all sorts of things whether it's two
chairs opposite each other or two
handstand blocks
simply hold on and then raise your legs
another easier variation of course is to
not straighten out the legs but to
simply hold yourself in a tuck position
like this and if you want a tough
progression all you can do is hold
yourself in that l-sit for as long as
you can and when you fatigue
pull into that tuck position and that'll
do it however i think what i would
slightly prefer for most people is that
instead of being in the tuck position
you simply hold yourself in as good a
nail position as you can because this
way you're still working on that
mobility you're still working against
the tension in the antagonistic muscles
and that way we're building towards what
we actually want to achieve of course
another variation is to perform an
assisted l-sit and to do that you can
obviously get a friend to hold your legs
you can use a resistance band that's
hanging off of something or gymnastics
rings or you can simply
rest your feet on the ground slightly
lift them as much as you can
but if you don't clear the ground then
that's fine and it'll get better as you
go so on this channel i always say that
you shouldn't just focus on gaining the
skills it's actually the underlying
traits that are more important so if you
want to be able to do the l-sit or the
v-sit then what you really want to be
working on is that compressive strength
and one way you can do this is with a
move from gymnastic strength training
called the pike pulse so you're going to
sit on the ground like straight out
front of you locked out then you're
going to lean forwards with your hands
and lean slightly forwards trying not to
round the lumbar spine too much and then
you're just going to pulse the legs up
like this and you'll immediately feel it
and as you get better at this you can
lean forwards and forwards i can't what
you want to try not to do is to rock
like this because then you're not
actually working what you're trying to
work
if you stick that into your workouts
that will help you to gain the mobility
and the strength you need a lot quicker
so another move you can do to stretch
your hamstrings that i've really liked
recently is called the elephant walk and
i got this once again from knees over
toes guy put your hands on the floor in
front of you try not to round the lower
back too much and you are allowed to
bend the knees on this occasion and what
you're going to do then is you're going
to take it in turns to straighten one of
the knees and then you're going to feel
that hamstring stretch on that side and
what you're going to do over time is
bring the hands closer to you as you are
able to and this is a great way to
really rapidly improve your hamstring
mobility and the great thing about this
one is that because you're only moving
one leg at a time you're going to reduce
the tendency there to round that lower
back which can sometimes prevent you
from getting the full stretch on the
hamstring sometimes it can also lead to
a bit of unwanted pain there one thing
you can do of course if you can't get
into an l-sit or a visa is to swing your
legs into that position and then to
control the descent as much as possible
and that's a really good way to hack
your way into this essentially like
doing a cheat with a dumbbell curl
of course one of the most famous and
well-known variations is the v-sit this
is where you're going to be bringing
your legs up a lot higher and what you
can do here is to bring your hips
forward slightly and at the same time it
is okay to bend your arms slightly if
you need to lean back into it more this
is obviously going to really challenge
that compressive strength this is a
really difficult move to do and you of
course shouldn't expect to be able to
just launch straight into a v-sit so
very few people can do it
grant basically to get here all you want
to do is keep practicing your l-sit make
sure you're actively trying to raise
those legs not just sitting there
passively and then if you do your pike
pulses and your elephant walks on top of
that any other hamstring stretches
you'll get there eventually
i hope obviously another really cool
variation you can do is the l-sit to
handstand and as the name suggests
you're going from an l-sit into a
handstand by doing this you get all the
benefits of the l-sit and all the
benefits of a handstand you can add a
little handstand press in there and this
makes a hybrid movement obviously it's a
tricky movement to build up to if you
practice the l-sit and the handstand
separately eventually you can connect
them what you want to do is have a
little bit of momentum going out of the
l-sit or the v-sit to help carry you up
try not to bend the arms too much and
that'll minimize the amount of handstand
press you need to do and another
variation you can do of course is to
just put some kind of ankle weights on
or you can even hold a medicine ball
between your feet and conversely as
grant just pointed out if you take your
shoes off when you're practicing the
l-sit and v-sit actually make it easier
and you can get even higher
thanks so much for watching guys i hope
you found this video useful and
interesting if you did then please leave
a like and share around that'll help me
out immensely let me know if you do
l-sits in the comments and what your
favorite variations are thanks again to
grant stevens for helping me out filming
today and getting some really dynamic
shots be sure to check out his channel
for martial arts and training and
lifestyle advice i'll put a link to that
in description down below if you like
this kind of training that focuses not
just on aesthetics and strength but on
every aspect of physical performance
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training there's a discount on right now
and again you'll find the link in the
description down below i've also got a
print book functional training and
beyond which is an introduction to
functional training available through
amazon and all good bookstores either
way thanks so much for watching this one
and i'll see you next time
bye for now